Hey, how's it going? I'm Casey Ford Alexander.
I'm a member of the Class of 2010 and I'm
in "THR 317: Theatrical Design" with a focus
on set design.
Well, we had two projects this year, and it
was clear even from the first class that this
really wasn't a class about set design, quote-unquote.
It was more about production design and imagining
the entire aesthetic; a look and a feel that
was informed by the text. The first project
we worked on was Oedipus, and I designed for
a specific space: the Delacorte Theater in
Central Park. And I was thinking a lot about
textures and landscapes that were informed
by the totally lifeless, dead and post-apocalyptic
setting that was Thebes.
I think it's interesting to set this in his
world, because then you get to see Nina break
out of it. And so she's the kind of rock chick
rebel I saw her as. I think she goes from
being this really all-out colorful teenage
rebel into -- she grows up -- she becomes
a woman. And I think the visual process of
that is seeing her become a lot more monochromatic
and sexual, as opposed to childish ... a real
world that he never envisaged and I think
that's where ... there are things that happen
with the chalk markings throughout the play.
But I think the most significant moment is
at the end when Nina erases the things of
her speech that he had written for her to
say.
In my production of The Seagull, actors are
immersed in a white world reminiscent of a
rehearsal room or a sound stage.
During Acts I and II, Konstantin projects
images onto a white brick wall to create facsimiles
of the locales in the play. The brick wall
is removed for Acts III and IV. Then, the
projected surround becomes the world of the
play.
Overall, it was a fantastic class. We talked
so much more about art and what it means to
tell a story on stage and how to put that
in visuals than we did about how to simply
building sets, building specific pieces for
the stage. It was a class about exploring
art, what it means to tell a story through
theater, what it means to make use of the
pinnacle of human creativity that is theater:
the collaborative art form. So, it was a fantastic
class, and I enjoyed my time with Riccardo
and with all the classmates who just brought
such cool energy and cool ideas to the class.
It was a really great experience.